breaking news overnight a luxury condo
complex just outside miami beach florida
has partially collapsed leaving a
mountain of debris
these are new images we're seeing as the
sun came up this morning you can see
a police officer standing on top of the
rubble
and the stories of the building stacked
up below at least a third
of the 12-story building crumbled around
two this morning local time
surfside's mayor charles burkett talked
to reporters about
how many people may have been in the
building
you talk to the building manager about
that and
they don't log owners when they come in
and out but they log guests
so we do have a log of guests but we
don't have a log of owners
and the building manager is
has intimated to me that the building
was substantially full
manuel bajorkas is at the scene manny
what else do we know at this point
well anthony as you heard in our 7 a.m
hour the mayor confirmed to me that
there is at least
one fatality here and 10 people we know
of have been rushed to hospitals but
those numbers unfortunately
are almost certain to rise as the search
and rescue effort continues at the
building just behind us here the
collapse on the other side i want to
bring in barry cohen
you can see the collapse from your
apartment and you were able to get out
just in time
that's correct how did you know to get
out
well we opened up the door well
first we heard a crash of lightning i
thought it was lightning
and it went on for 30 seconds i'd say at
least
and it was as loud as you could ever the
loudest thing i've ever heard
now i know what a building collapsing
sounds like
and um we went out on our balcony and
surfside police were already there
and we said what what should we do and
um they said go back inside we don't
know what's going on
and then um we
went out of our apartment to try to get
out of the building
and we opened up the door to our
apartment and there used to be a
100 yard lobby
hallway and it was rubble
gone gone i know that
your heart is with all of the people who
may have been
crushed is the fear in there but you
keep
smiling when you came to us earlier you
just keep saying
i'm so happy to be alive i'm
i'm always smiling and i'm always happy
to be alive i've had a great
life where i've had challenges that i've
overcome them
uh many many times and um
i i'm just
that's how i approach everything all
right barry we're happy that you're
alive as well
as the investigation continues here the
search and rescue mission continues here
um there is just a lot to be learned
here
as the rescuers continue to search
through the rubble
behind us eureka
florida thank you so much